the moon's surface is made up of
long-dead volcanoes and impact craters
from asteroids but have you ever
wondered what might be inside it we
could find out one day by digging a
tunnel through the moon how long would
this take what mysteries would we find
inside and how would gravity affect our
dig this is what if and here's what
would happen if we dug a tunnel through
the moon
unlike the Earth's layers we don't know
much about what's inside our Moon but we
do know to get through it you'd need to
dig over 3,000 kilometers and with
today's technology doing something like
this would take about 1,300 years but
what if we managed to fast forward this
with more advanced technology what would
happen then to start our journey through
the moon we'd first want to choose an
area that would give us a head start the
best choice here would be the South Pole
Aitken Basin this is a massive Basin
that's eight kilometres deep for
comparison the deepest hole on earth is
12 point 2 kilometres
now it's time to start digging
the first layer you'd need to worry
about would be the moon's regolith also
known as the moon's outer crust it may
not seem like it at first but this layer
is surprisingly dangerous regolith is
billions of years of crushed asteroids
and moon dust it's razor sharp and very
fine and can easily get into your suit
and your drill which will wear them down
over time and make sure you don't
accidentally impale any of this stuff as
it can cause lung cancer you'll be
digging through the regolith layer for
up to 15 metres until you reach the
lunar crust this layer is made up of
bedrock and it's where you might make
some money since rocks in the crust
contain lots of titanium and aluminum
you'll also be able to find iron calcium
and magnesium we could either bring
these back to earth or use them to help
us colonize the moon this layer is about
100 kilometers deep once you're through
it you'll then have to deal with the
lithosphere this layer used to be magma
that would supply the moon's volcanoes
but thankfully it's cooled and is now
solid what would be less thankful for is
that this layer is nearly 1,000
kilometers deep so you'd keep drilling
and drilling and drilling and drilling
until you've finally reached the
asthenosphere what's different here is
that this layer is made up of molten
lava at this point your journey would
definitely be over as you'll be facing
temperatures of up to 1500 degrees but
we'll give you a special suit to help
you survive this on a special drill to
now you wouldn't be drilling at this
point instead you'd be trying to swim
your way through this magma and as you
get past this you'll be met with another
liquid but this time it will be liquid
iron which is the outer layer of the
moon's core its radius is roughly 330
kilometers so let's hope your suit can
still withstand the immense heat and as
you drill your way through these
thousands of kilometres you'll notice
that the gravity has been changing as
you reach the center of the moon the
gravity will reach zero and you'll be
completely weightless floating in the
moon's inner core made of solid iron so
now that you've reached the center it's
time to make your way back out through
the outer core out through the
asthenosphere then the lithosphere inner
crust and finally the regolith layer and
drilling through wouldn't take as long
as it did the first time that's because
the inner crust is about 40 kilometers
thinner on this side of the Moon which
is the site that faces the earth digging
through the moon has some benefits but
overall it wouldn't be worth it
after all this project would take
thirteen hundred years and who wants to
wait that long
maybe building a time machine would help
but we'll leave that story for another
what-if
[Music]